manuela qu'éclaire mondésir bonjour
manche andres 1 et bonjour aux
sanitaires alors cela fait maintenant
deux ans et demi que vous êtes député
néanmoins vous avez décidé de vous
présenter pour les élections municipales
et communautaires à saint joseph
pourquoi vouloir ce mandat de maire
alors que vous êtes une toute récente
députés mais le mandat de maire c'est
pas elle n'est pas ce panier
d'aujourd'hui 1 c'est ce qui depuis 2001
m'a motivé pour m'engager dans la vie
politique de mon pays de ma commune donc
c'est tout naturellement que je suis que
je reviens à mon projet initial qui est
de m'investir pour ma commune
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose de
particulier qui vous a fait prendre
cette décision parce que compte tenu de
la loi concernant le cumul des mandats
si vous êtes élu maire par le conseil
municipal au mois de mars
si vous avez gagné remporté des
élections et que votre conseil municipal
vous porter à la tête de l'édilité
joséphine vous serez contrainte de
devoir abandonner votre mandat de député
tout à fait je suis consciente et c'est
en toute connaissance de cause que j'ai
pris la décision et fait le choix
d'aller aux municipales à saint joseph
parce que je vous avoue que souvent
quand je suis ces derniers temps
particulièrement quand je suis dans
l'hémicycle où je vois là on traite des
dossiers en traite des dervallières des
loin on discute sur les projets de loi
et pendant ce temps ma commune
bon voilà il ya une actualité qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas rose il ya quand je
retourne sur le terrain est vraiment
c'est ma priorité être toujours en
connexion avec le terrain mais main et
un député je n'ai jamais lâché le
terrain
mais voilà il ya des retours aidés donc
il ya des circonstances particulières
quand même et qui vous qui vous ont
amené à vous dire
là faut que j'y aille oui il faut qu'ils
aillent pourquoi être à part guy quand
justement à la maison les choses ne sont
pas alors brièvement préciser nous donc
le quel groupe vous vous supporte vous
présente en tant que tête de liste et le
nom de votre liste alors je suis une
femme totalement autonome
l'image est un mouvement que j'ai créée
il ya un peu plus d'un an avec qui
s'appelle nouvelle alternative citoyenne
et c'est ça la démarche justement
entière je crois que dans le nom de ce
mouvement on entend vraiment la matière
la démarche de la liste des gants
nouvelle alternative citoyenne plus tôt
sinon le nom de la liste il y en a je
pousse à joseph vend ses avants voyait
le reste toujours dans le même thème
c'est la population les citoyens
ensemble nous pouvons nous associer pour
faire les choses alors manu la queue car
mon désir vous êtes déjà conseillère
municipale me semble que oui j'étais
adjointe au maire au maire au maire oui
il ne se représente pas on équipe
actuelle quels sont vos rapports avec
d'abord le maire sortant qui ne se
représente pas monsieur jeanne rose et
puis avec cette équipe parce qu'il ya
des personnes qui se retrouvent sur
votre liste dans voulu tout renouveler
moment avec le avec le maire de saint
joseph malé des gens totalement cordiaux
en fonction de nos disponibilités
évidemment on se voit pas souvent je
vais pas on se voit pas souvent on
n'échange pas souvent mais je crois que
on se respecte chacun et je crois que
c'est la base d'une relation et d'une
collaboration au sein de la municipalité
bon c'est ce qui nous a réunis puis
maintenant je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a
besoin de renouveau on a besoin de
changement et je besoin d'une belle
dynamique
aujourd'hui au sein du conseil municipal
qui se retrouve avec vous n'en faites
tous mais à part deux ou trois comme
femme et dynamique qui en vraiment le
sens maternelle le sens de la qui porte
leur commune ben voilà et aussi beaucoup
de jeunes
vous revendiquez ne serait ce qu une
part de l'héritage des mandatures
d'athanase jeanne rose puisque vous
étiez avec lui vous avez collaboré vous
étiez adjointe
parce que sur ceux dans ce domaine là
vous avez un concurrent en la personne
de monsieur simon morin qui lui aussi
est quasiment dans la même situation que
vous oui le bilan alors le bilan actuel
le bilan de dieu de la dernière
mandature
ce n'est pas le mien c'est le résultat
d'une d'une voiture d'une action qui
date de 2002 la mandature de 2018
poursuivi en 2014
bon le 2008 pardon poursuivi en 2014 jeu
ce sera au premier adjoint et maire
d'assumer cet adjoint simon moore en
voilà d'assumer cela
moi ce que je peux indiquer juste pour
apple a changé en deux eurent à assumer
les fonctions des fonctions au sein de
l'acas m
je crois que sur le transport c'est si
le bilan de deux mois de mal à mon désir
sur la question du de la propreté et du
service
on va dire d'enlèvement d'ordures
ménagères proche des habitations
notamment dans les petites voix sait
aussi qu'on va pas faire un bilan
par contre comme le temps passe très
vite et qui nous restent vraiment qu'à
peine je crois quelques secondes ou une
minute
oui ça va très vite résumé nous quel est
votre la proposition phare que vous
voulez faire donc au joséphine et au
josefa pour la prochaine mandature et
que vous voudriez mettre en oeuvre si
vous êtes élu en mars prochain
alors je crois que je parlerai
particulièrement de deux actions mais
tout ça c'est vraiment dans le cadre du
bien-être et de pas dire du vivre
ensemble
alors la question de la sécurité qu'on
puisse qu'il faut le dire la sécurité et
la tranquillité urbaine c'est une des
priorités de même de ma mandature ce qui
permettra une redynamisation du commerce
et puis un accompagnement des jeunes on
les pointe souvent du doigt mais je suis
désolé nous portons aussi cette
responsabilité n'est plus le deuxième
volet c'est la notion de culture là
aussi la l'identité moi je veux crier
l'office de la culture de saint joseph
sur un statut particulier et qui pourra
vraiment que ya une belle dynamique vous
qu'on puisse voir saint-joseph autrement
pas seulement les joseph 1 mais ceux
d'ailleurs qui puisse voir autrement les
choses et fin merci manuel aac et
clermont désir merci ça aux cadis
spécial municipal donc réalisé par
audrey calixte